une question présente et vous bernard
charreyre député des yvelines de
quelconques vous êtes du groupe
socialiste c'est heavy metal pendant un
bon groupe mais pourquoi pas vous êtes
débuté depuis combien de temps dix ans
est-ce que c'est plus facile quand on
est député pour se tirer des gonzesses à
ce que ça aide
ça je pense que cela dépende pas du rôle
de de la profession que l'on fait quand
on est député est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après pour
conclure écoutez ce n'est pas une
question sérieuse posée nous une
question sur la fin il faudrait pas
question pour moi sérieuse parce que des
fois on est sur un coup on est sur le on
est à deux doigts et la nana se casse
je comprends pas du tout son soutien
parfois il est là qu ils sont
impressionnés d'aynac on n'aurait pas
pensé m'en tirer mais comme on le député
hop on peut leur mettre une cartouche
c'est une plaisanterie
non c'est une vraie question messieurs
juste une question vous vous teniez la
main ce qu'il y a des relations
homosexuelles
parmi les hommes politiques font des
rapports ont ce n'est pas la main
d'abord si vous êtes garé c'est un petit
peu vous avez eu un début des jeux vous
avez une question jean-pierre quand on
est connu c'est plus facile avec les
gonzesses mais c'est plus difficile si
forcément plus difficile parce qu'il met
des lunettes noires
mais bon une question quand on est un
homme politique est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après d'abord
d'abord pourquoi me tutoyer la presse
que je t'aime bien
bon vous devrez sympathique on a pas on
n'a pas vécu ensemble comme ça parce que
j'ai pas volé il est ensemble
non je suis la barrière députée maire de
pau et vous avez payé d'attouchements
sexuels avec j'adore yvette et je crois
que ça vaut mieux la doré que tout le
reste votre avis est ce qu'elle est
bonne mais yvette j'étais pas jacques
est simplement est ce que le fait d'être
connu en politique ça sert avec les
conseils c'est à dire que depuis que je
ai rencontré ma femme qui est
fantastique
alors les gonzesses ne me concerne plus
plu du tout tu t'es fait coupé par un
veto au pas du tout raymond se tutoie
pas alors un bien on se vouvoie pas
voilà dit on ne parle pas chez ben voilà
barock'n roll 1
ils ont tous une langue de bois mais à
les entendre ils s'en servent jamais
ouais
en tous les cas pour son deuxième voyage
de la chambre des députés c'est encore
mieux que le premier je propose qu'on
l'applaudisse non c'est beau la liberté
quand même non oui oui à faire ça à la
télévision d'un mobile c'est très bon
yann et je crois que quand même nom mais
il faut lorsque leurs relativement
récent ouais non mais c'est vrai il faut
reconnaître quand même parce que moi
j'ai connu une époque où quand même on
ne pouvait pas tout dire non moi aussi
je les connais donc des emplois du grand
chose ils ont dit ce que tu leur as nuit
et toi tu as pu le faire ouais parce que
je découvre
non parce qu'il ya des gens qui t'ont
laissé faire ouais si d'éclat